con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar del enclave ruso de
kaliningrado rusia ya denunció el
bloqueo parcial del tránsito de
mercancías a sesión enclave báltico por
parte de lituania que calificó de la
violación del derecho internacional por
parte de ese país y también por supuesto
de la unión europea- kaliningrado
recordemos es un enclave que está
separado del resto de rusia y tiene
frontera con dos países de la unión
europea y de la otan lituania y polonia
en el año 1994 rusia y la europea
pactaron entonces un acuerdo de
colaboración y cooperación donde se
comprometieron a respetar la libertad de
tránsito a través de sus territorios
kaliningrado depende de un corredor
ferroviario lo que une al territorio
continental ruso a través de belarús y
por donde recibe la mayor parte de los
productos que necesita para su economía
lituana puso en efecto entonces las
naciones europeas prohibiendo el uso de
un ferrocarril para enviar carbón
metales o productos electrónicos y otras
mercancías sancionadas moscú ya ha
advertido que su respuesta podría ser
no solamente diplomática vamos a ver
entonces en qué contexto y qué quiere
decir con estas declaraciones rusas con
nuestro primer invitado el día del
doctor lajos szaszdi león borja él es
analista de relaciones internacionales y
estudios estratégicos de fuerzas
terrestres navales y aéreas y espaciales
también rusas es profesor adjunto de la
universidad interamericana de puerto
rico doctor gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
muy buen día y por supuesto primero
quiero preguntarle la importancia
histórica y estratégica de este enclave
para rusia explíquenos un poco si bueno
es realmente en forma por parte de lo
que sería rusia en aquel entonces la
unión soviética en
1945 pero era la primera vez en la
historia al menos a mi conocimiento que
ha sido parte de rusia ese territorio
que antes era parte de prusia oriental y
cómo proceden tal había sido
originalmente parte del reino de polonia
pero bajo la administración de los
caballeros teutones una orden militar
monástica como los templarios
cuando el hospital y bueno con la
reforma protestante el gran maestre la
orden de los doctores alberto se hizo
luterano y se apropió todas las
propiedades de la iglesia de la orden
monástica guerrera de los teutones y se
hizo duque de prusia bajo el rey de
polonia eventualmente se convierte en el
reino de prusia independiente y
eventualmente pues como parte alemania
su dinastía hohenzollern son los
emperadores de el segundo rey segundo
imperio que sucumbe con la primera
guerra mundial con la derrota alemana
allí y bueno era alemán alemán fundado
en el siglo 13 copérnico estuvo allí e
brevemente
immanuel kant pues estuvo ayer a su
ciudad que nix berg vamos a decirlo hoy
en día llamada kaliningrado y en el
distrito de kaliningrado de la
federación rusa originalmente ha fundado
para la unión soviética con la derrota
de alemania de la alemania de hitler
y bueno cuando era de la unión soviética
tenía contacto directo con territorio
soviético porque como saben la unión
soviética
el líder soviético al pactar con adolfo
hitler en los pactos molotov ribbentrop
que dieron lugar a la invasión de
polonia el comienzo a la segunda guerra
mundial pues alemania le da permiso a
stalin para quedarse con lituania
letonia estonia que era miembros de la
sociedad en acción es la precursora de
las naciones unidas- países neutrales
independientes soberanos entonces pues
en claro bajo el puente terrestre de
lituania soviética después de 1940 y
después de la derrota alemana de 1000
después de 1944 oa través de bielorrusia
también república socialista soviética
no había problema había contacto entre
kaliningrado que era un distrito
especial militar naval con el resto la
unión soviética cae la unión soviética
se independiza en lituania letonia
estonia bielorrusia que el pacto de
varsovia obviamente queda aislada
kaliningrado antigua königsberg y
entonces bueno ha sido una región
militar especial con ese estatus creo
que hasta 2010 pero ahí es donde está la
sede el general de la flota del mar
báltico rusa que una de las cuatro
flotas principales junto con la del mar
negro la del norte o septentrional
basada en múrmansk
y bueno está la flota del pacífico hay
como 12 mil tropas más o menos que
llegaron a tener
1999 como 600 500 tanques probablemente
no tengan tanto ahora en aquel entonces
como 550 lanzacohetes de artillería de
350 piezas artillería pesada pero
probablemente menos ahora habrá doctor
larios rusia ante todo este panorama y
alexis a lituania que revirtiera la
medida que consideran el gobierno ruso
abiertamente hostil contra su
ejecutividad seguro que si el tránsito
de mercancías entre esta región de
kaliningrado y el resto de la federación
rusa a través de obviamente lituania no
se restablece por completo entonces se
reserva el derecho a tomar medidas para
proteger sus intereses nacionales
también dijeron últimamente que estas
medidas no serían completamente digamos
diplomáticas no solamente diplomáticas
tipo de respuesta se puede esperar
entonces por moscú más allá de la
diplomática se puede también tomar esto
como una amenaza si ciertamente y no
olvidemos que han estado desde moscú
tanto vladimir putin como sus altos
miembros de su gobierno de su propaganda
mediática o incluso robos sin el
director de roscósmos de la agencia
espacial rusa amenazando con armas
nucleares y destruir por ejemplo el
reino unido o eeuu etcétera
amenazando con armas nucleares
veladamente puedan finlandia suecia que
quieren ser de la otan así que esas
amenazas han de tomarse seriamente